and then um as I was going through just
starting to think about all the things
that have happened since kind of um
you know the 2020 period it's quite
amazing really I mean there's been a
huge number of developments that give me
cause for optimism and and also I mean
I'm so privileged I've I I I know Matt
so a worker because I've actually
started trying to understand physics by
following following some of Matt's work
frankly and as a as a journalist who's
somewhat deficient in understanding
physics and Mathematics I uh I I take my
head off to you good sir because you've
been able to popularize the subject
matter that I keenly think I need to
understand and uh I'm kind of a fanboy
of yours so it's a real privilege to
meet you that's that's really wonderful
to hear um it's always nice to know that
we're not wasting our time
yeah because you never know you know we
film in a a room staring at a camera
um there's no direct contact with anyone
that we're that I'm speaking to and so
hearing this sort of thing is
it's uplifting but even if not
do you still feel like you're having a
tremendous amount of fun
so for me at least like I'm having fun
right now I'm having fun whenever I
speak to guests like Ross solo Matt solo
even if it wasn't seen by many people I
wouldn't put it out and it's a
ridiculous so frequently but thing to do
is a job and I'm grateful to be able to
very much just to follow curiosity
um professionally
Ross you also have a podcast
can you state the name I do yes myself
and Bryce zabel my colleague in crime
Bryce is based in Los Angeles and he's a
a very well respected Hollywood uh
producer and screenwriter he's also
responsible for the Dark Skies series
and um uh he and I do a podcast called
need to know which is I guess an attempt
at a journalistic analysis uh news
program that looks at the phenomenon in
his
journalistically open-eyed open
open-minded way as possible
um and uh it's uh I'm happy to say it's
thriving uh the the level of public
interest at the moment in the in the
phenomenon of uaps if there is such a
term this um is absolutely amazing I I
have to admit uh Kurt I I um I almost
missed your invitation to this event
because I have had so many emails and
messages from people from all over the
world who who seem to think that this
journalist in Australia has incredible
resources to be able to investigate
stuff and people are sending the
original documents and witness accounts
and statements and uh it's it's all a
bit overwhelming but also it's it's it's
flattering because what it recognizes is
something that I think is really
deficient at the moment which is that
there is a
a real shortage of objective analytical
news media engaging with what I think is
the biggest story of the moment I mean I
I'm I'm excited by what's going on in
modern science right now I I love I'm
just such a fan of the stuff coming out
of the James Webb Telescope and um it's
it's so exciting to see this Cutting
Edge technology revealing stuff about
the universe that we don't know and how
could people not be engaged in a similar
in a similar way with what's being
somewhat begrudgingly admitted by the
United States government and to a less a
degree by other governments that there
is a phenomenon a mystery out there that
they don't understand
and none of us are saying it's little
green aliens despite what Mr Jenkins of
the Wall Street Journal or Mr Barnes of
the New York Times say frankly we just
don't know that there's a there's a
phenomenon which is a genuine mystery
that is confounding the best brains in
the in the Pentagon and the intelligence
community and I can tell you it's also
befuddling people in our um intelligence
services and defense community in
Australia even though they don't want to
talk about it and um it's it's
fascinating because
there is something out there that is
worthy of investigation and ultimately
at the heart of it good science as we
all know is about being willing to
engage with
the unknown and try and understand it
and uh I I think 2023 promises to be
quite an exciting year
speaking of the unknown these the
following threes are Taylor and Sorensen
and nikolaj they may be unknown to the
majority of the people here and they
shouldn't be so please I'm going to get
you all to introduce yourselves and give
it a bit a brief overview as to what
your submission to the contest was and
then if you have any questions for Matt
or Ross please please ask so Tyler
starting with you then Sorensen then
nikolaj and thank you all
uh yeah thank you for having me on here
today uh my submission was about
what uh a Theory of Everything Is
essentially and what the process is like
of
developing one and proposing one and
it's quite a unique uh experience and it
it leads to a lot of lessons that I
don't think can really be uh
learned outside of that process so that
was what my uh my entry primarily
focused on
it was called theories of everything a
how-to guide
okay so I'll place that again in the
description I'll try and pin it well
right now in Sorensen
hello can you hear me yes okay and my
submission is called time independent
solution to electron orientation
and it starts I started by
dividing some a little rounded equations
and and seeing that instead of using a
cake condition you can define a electric
sign component
and then uh yeah and then this when you
use this time command you get some
Quantum like effects
in a large amount of distance and then I
could be aware wider and
and find some time independent solutions
for for this uh
thank you
thank you and nikolaj and correct me if
I'm mispronouncing your name and if I
don't think I've met any of you Tyler
we've spoken but I haven't met you so
this is a pleasure so firstly so
great great Nicholas
yeah well I'm from Denmark so it's
pronounced neighbor live but it's it's
not sorry sorry Nikolai oh my gosh
well thank you for always it's a nice
little idea to this could thank you well
I'm I'm
uh I've done something with different uh
I've tried to sketch a model for
fundamental nature reality but it's uh
well it's an it's a physical idealistic
model it's
it has some similarities with another
Castro's use I think and it's based on a
paper that was published last year and
and I have uh I've taken some elements
from a dentist Mystic called Martino's
he has a presented a comprehensive
metaphysical system and I take some core
aspects of his system and
uh well translated them into
academic philosophical language one
might say in order to
uh to sketch this um
this model for the fundamental nature of
reality it's a it's a triadic model so
it's
the basic concept is that nature is is
it's a triadic structure that kind of
generates Consciousness and experience
so yeah well Matt has to get going and
Matt like it's I thank you for coming on
at spending again like your precious
time your holiday time thank you for
coming on twice on toe inventing reality
is an Indiegogo which is just read the
description of it I'm going to briefly
read it what is reality reality has
proved strange beyond our intuitions and
exciting
New Vision is emerging is reductionism
dead
can physics ever hope to find ground
truth the toe themes if you're
interested in that then go to
go to this the link hold on just this
link right here which will be in the
description and check out Matt's
Indiegogo as well as PBS space time and
Matt do you have any parting words and
if anyone has a quick question for Matt
that he can answer in 30 seconds then
please ask it now
else Matt just say goodbye
um no parting words except thank you
Kurt it's really good to be here again
uh I hope we can make it make it regular
um
and maybe find a way to get you on space
so I don't know we don't do that sort of
thing but maybe we should
maybe we should mix it up
um yeah I'm gonna hold you to that we
have we we have the same goal
um so I appreciate the chance to join
the conversation the the incredible
conversation that you have curated among
all these uh all these great minds
um
yeah thank you Matt
okay take care man yeah man all right
appreciate it
Okay Ross
Ross it's so good to see you it's it's
like honestly thank you again thank you
too for for spending such time with me I
know that you said this is
precious family time and I imagine I I
can imagine just how much stress you're
under and how many projects you're
juggling with atop family commitments
were you able to get any breathing room
so far over the course of the past 10
days it's been a beautiful Break
um it's funny actually because one of
the things that
um I don't know about you guys you are
the people that when I'm in done time
especially when I'm doing things like um
I I live on a little farm and I
constantly have to mow it because all
it's doing at the moment here in
Australia is raining and lots of
sunshine and so we have days of rain and
days of sunshine and my grass is just
growing constantly so for me it's a
constant battle against Grass and um I'm
um I I think somebody could do a
scientific courtesy and develop grass
that grows to a certain length and stops
growing then the rest of us don't have
to mow it anymore but when I'm doing my
mowing I find I do some of my best
thinking and it's that it's that idea
that by doing a task that has become so
autonomic so so you know something that
you don't even think about when you're
doing it you start thinking about big
things and um I love this time of year
because it's a genuinely creative time
of the year the rest of the year you're
so busy that you don't really get time
to stop and think and be creative and
I'm intrigued it's one of the things
I've actually been thinking of writing a
book about this is the number of
people that I've been talking to in the
the mystery behind the phenomenon
the UAP phenomenon the sort of the weird
paranormal world of people saying that
they've had these extraordinary
experiences the number of times people
say to me they've had downloads
where they literally all of a sudden
wake up and um and they've got these
incredible ideas in their head and then
I started researching it recently and I
was fascinated to read that um James
Crick the uh the the the person who
conceived the shape of the DNA helix
um he said that the whole idea of the
shape of DNA came to him in a dream
and then I started Googling and and
pulling out books off my shelf and it
really is it's fascinating how many
scientists
scribe that the moment of great
inspiration that they had where they
they suddenly realized an idea or or
they suddenly be able to crystallize a
concept in their brain and they describe
being in a dream state or um not really
focusing in the intense way that we do
focus when we focus on things to try and
study and I just wonder sometimes
whether there's some aspect of the brain
that
allows us to work on things in the
background that we haven't yet described
because that's my time of the year I I
love this time of the year because it's
a creative time of the year ideas start
bobbing into my head about what my next
book might be or because I'm a an
investigative journalist for a TV show
here in Australia I I also think about
what what the next story should be
and uh there's a nervous but um
interested part of me that's really
interested in the um the culture wars
right now I'm I'm fascinated by the war
on woke uh the fact that um it's
becoming a heresy now to
um to uh just to use certain language
you know you the the slightly Marxist
culture wars that dictate what language
we will use to describe gender and
whilst I'm absolutely fulsome advocate
of friends of mine who've decided to
transition I don't like the way language
is being appropriated and uh I think
they must write a book at it booking it
somewhere is there something different
about that is there something there that
strikes you
as
I think um and again I'm actually
nervous even discussing this really
brought it up yeah but uh no and I I
think that universally around the world
what we're seeing is an attempt by
a
particular type of thinking to capture
ideas by
making certain ideas a transgression
from culturally accepted imperatives and
it's it's the fact that there does need
I think there needs to be an open and
public discussion about
what constitutes gender
uh I did a story once about a beautiful
woman who I accept as a woman called Kim
Petra and uh she was a born biologically
a boy in Germany Austria and we um I
went across from Australia thinking this
is all a load of nonsense you know
there's no such thing as transgenders
and stuff like that and
she was this most beautiful young woman
and in return for shooting her first
music video we got the opportunity to um
to interview her about her transition
and and why she um she decided that she
was a woman and the uh the German
Austrian authorities allowed us to
interview her psychiatrists and the the
people who'd made the um uh the decision
that she should be the youngest person
ever to be allowed to undergo the
hormone therapy and then eventually the
surgery and
um I love the fact that she's now I
think performing in Los Angeles and
doing a very successful career as a
beautiful young woman so I guess I'm
probably more open-minded than a lot of
people about gender but at the same time
I I don't like the way that
the cultural Wars have appropriated
things and you're not allowed to raise
things and I like the way JK Rowling was
treated for saying what she said she
wrote a beautiful 3000 word essay and
got vilified for um uh essentially
standing up for
people who who challenged cultural
imperatives about what constitutes
gender and I think there's a discussion
there that needs to be had maybe I'm
just Reckless to maybe I maybe I just
didn't get attracted to contrarian areas
that such as uaps that people shouldn't
go near you know us media should do as
we're told and not go into these areas
of dangerous journalism where you get
into areas that are sensitive and taboo
well you're in an already dangerous at
least sensitive at least marketable area
which is UFOs and it shouldn't be but
one of the things I've noticed this year
by the way that one of the things I've
noticed this year that has really scared
me a little is the
the nastiness that is starting to
develop on social media uh the
around anybody that you know I've taken
quite a public position in saying as I
constantly do that the phenomenon is
real that whatever it is it's a genuine
mystery acknowledged us so you feel like
it's gotten nastier I feel like it's
gotten more welcoming and more
acceptable
I suspect targeted troll campaigns you
know um uh there's a
um somebody out there doesn't like
people
like me rocking the boat and asking
questions about the phenomenon and um
there are a number of uh people who
basically made up their work to try and
pull down people who Express a view
that's opposite to the um
to the uh the accepted reality and uh I
I you know the bottom line is um I I
think we should ground our
investigations in solid science
um but then this is just hold on to that
thought Ross sorry because I I rudely am
having Tyler and Nikolai and Nikolai
sorry and and nud if I'm even
pronouncing that correctly sorry
Sorenson I'll at least say it which I
can moderately or at least passively
pronounce
I'm I'm having you all here and and
you're probably wondering like well can
I come in do I have a question can I say
something so just so you know there's
only about two minutes left for for you
all before I have to let in other people
and actually I have to go on a walking
break because my legs are just so stiff
my neck as well
but if you all have any questions for
Ross then please like please do ask
okay I have a question
have you seen that a few weeks ago there
was a itchy girl who make a YouTube
channel
can you repeat that once once more yes
uh I ask you if you have seen that two
weeks ago it was a
Ichi girl who made a YouTube channel
an at girl what she was claiming to be
alien was she yes
I mean how do we prove that I mean I I
this is the I care I'll tell you how my
brain works not when I get a message
like that I've had people contact me who
claim to be alien and I'm quite ruthless
with them you know I I I'm not taking
the piss with them but at the same time
I I expect people to be able to provide
evidence before I even engage and
um uh for example uh there's a um
while I went I won't cite this because
it's probably a bit dangerous but no I
mean I've been approached on multiple
occasions by people who purport to be
speaking on behalf of non-human
intelligence and I say great
fantastic
um provide me with some evidence of that
you know I'm not willing to engage
because until I I know that you are who
you say you are and in the same way that
scientists verify academic credentials
before they make a an assessment about
the validity of Assessments that people
make journalists have to look into the
provenance of
um
claims made by somebody and I mean I'm
fascinated for example
um there's a chap called Santos who's a
politician in the United States who's in
terrible trouble at the moment because
he's been fibbing about his um his
background and he's lied egregiously
about his academic qualifications his
work experience and even whether his
poor mother died of cancer and the
incredible thing is is that this is a
person who's made it into the Congress
no less and in all the verification
procedures that go on in the world you
would think that before somebody is
allowed to become a member of the
Congress of the United States you
actually verify their background and
make sure that they are who they say
they are and um in the same way I think
one of the things that I recognize as a
problem in the study of the phenomenon
of uaps UFOs is there are
so many people who are so credulous
um about certain things for example I
um I'll give you one example notice the
uh the Space Program uh people people
say there is a secret space program and
there are people like Corey good and
others who go around giving conferences
earning tens of thousands of dollars
claiming that they are people who've
fought for some kind of Intergalactic
um uh Army against other aliens and it's
all Preposterous in my view and I I've
basically said to people who've told me
about this and they say oh you know why
don't you why don't you engage with this
why don't you take it seriously and I
say well give me a good reason to do so
and and the bottom line is science
empirical science where you use data is
a really good starting point to make a
judgment as to whether or not something
should be engaged with so if somebody
contacts me as they have done saying
that they're alien I mean the Anjali
case is a classic
um this is a woman who claimed to have
had an extraordinary experience where
she went into a hill knit aliens and um
and she claimed that there would be an
opportunity for the media and um
selected Representatives I was on the
list at one stage to actually go and
meet these aliens and I was terribly
excited but very very very skeptical and
not not to anyone's surprise at all
system went away and
no I didn't know about the the fact that
there's a woman who's purporting to
benalian but it doesn't surprise me I
mean there are there are a lot of
um
there are a lot of odd
claims that are made but frankly I don't
think we need to look at odd claims we
just need to accept the fact that the
prevailing acknowledged officially
acknowledged mystery is enough for all
of us that we now are in a new paradigm
we're in a new paradigm where basically
the government of the United States and
to a lesser degree other governments
like the British government and I think
the French government's being pretty
good too and the Russians they're all
acknowledging in varying degrees in a
public way that there is a genuine
mystery involving a phenomenon that
manifests itself in the sky that is
apparently detectable on radar that does
weird things that are Beyond known human
science that appears to manifest itself
as as craft as technological objects and
I find that fascinating and I think it
should be investigated and for me that's
enough of a mystery I don't think we
need to
um
get too involved with people who make
claims that they can't substantiate
all right you just watched a clip from
an eight hour live stream Behemoth
Leviathan podcast from theories of
everything which is a channel where we
explore physics mathematics and
Consciousness what is the Theory of
Everything how do you merge Quantum
field Theory with General relativities
click here or in the description for the
full podcast where there are several
people make appearances all the way from
George Knapp to Jeremy Corbell to Gary
Nolan to Avi Loeb to John verveighkey to
Donald Hoffman to Michael Levin to Ian
mcgilchrist and 40 more all in one eight
hour long podcast links in the
description